you said you've written everything you
possibly can for money I'm curious
what's the difference between writing
for money and not writing for money well
uh that's a great question the
difference between writing for money and
not writing for money uh is more than
just being a mercenary I'm a working
writer which means I make a living or
have made a living for 45 years writing
uh other than teaching I haven't I don't
have a day job I never have uh since I
sold my first script so uh I have to
write what sells I have to write what
people are paying money for so that
means I'm often writing something that
isn't my first choice I spent the last
20 years to a large degree writing uh
children's animation well I wouldn't
have chosen to write children's
animation but what was paying so I
learned how to do it and I I've enjoyed
it and I've done some very good work
doing that so that's one distinction is
I'm not all I write my own projects
separately not for money you know I'll
write spec scripts continue to do it
always have sometimes they sell
sometimes they don't probably more often
than not spec scripts don't sell but uh
that's me that's me putting my best work
uh uh into the world but when I write
for money uh I'm trying to execute
someone else's Vision as well as I
possibly can um that's the one
distinction but it's not quite as
cold-blooded as all that because when
you write for money that means you're
writing for
a form that the producer thinks will get
that money back the money he's put into
it plus more plus a profit by definition
that means you're writing for an
audience there have to be people out
there who are going to watch this and
that's great training because left to
their own devices all writers are going
to tend to get lost in their own head
and just write what they want to write
and that's fine but they're often
disconnect from the audience if you
haven't had the experience of watching
uh an audience see your work I've been
lucky enough to have that experience
hundreds of times and it's been good for
me to see what audiences like what
audiences don't like what they respond
to what they don't respond to how they
respond uh is great training and I wish
every writer could have that experience
I have friends who are major
screenwriters but they may have only had
four or five movies made in their entire
20 30 years and even then very often it
wasn't really their movie somebody
rewrote it or the director changed it
and they and so they have a limited uh
amount of experience seeing an audience
respond to their work and what because I
have had that experience because I've
written for money on TV shows or TV
movies or movie movies uh but because
audiences responded to it and I was in
my job my paycheck depended on me uh
satisfying those audiences uh because of
that I've been more in touch with the
audience
than I usually than than most uh most
screenwriters probably are I'm curious
do you recall any interesting sort of
conversations where you've actually sat
in and heard uh positive and negative
and how that changed you or affected uh
further storytelling positive NE
negative from the audience you mean
right right if you've been fly on the
wall yeah for sure in terms of uh I did
spent much of my career early in my
career it's about 20 years
uh doing uh multicamera sitcoms and uh I
don't know if that's a common term
everybody knows but multicamera sitcoms
are shot with four cameras on a Sound
Stage like friends or Frasier Everybody
Loves Raymond that kind of thing and
there's an audience behind those cameras
responding to the scenes as if they were
a play they're performed like a play
scene by scene well because of that 20
years 22 Episodes of a season that's a
lot of of episodes that I either wrote
or co-wrote or worked on seeing an
audience respond and so especially in
comedy what you're looking for is that
verbal reaction a laugh if you get a
laugh it's great if you don't it's
usually not good uh so in terms of that
very often I'm constantly adjusting we
might adjust between takes very often
when typical multicamera sitcom you do
two takes usually sometimes three but
usually two takes of a scene and even in
the 5 10 minutes between each take when
the actors are being touched up for
their makeup and every cameras are going
back to position one uh the the writers
and producers are rushing in to try and
fix the joke or tweak this or make it
work better so it was a constant process
uh and I also learned that laughter
isn't the only way to read an audience
that uh I had a boss once who said you
know all I want in that first scene I'd
love to have a laugh in the first scene
but if I just get a a Gasper of moan or
something that suggests they're engaged
in the story or gold that's what you're
looking for you're looking for are they
engaged in the story are they leaning in
are they interested in whatever the
protagonist problem is and so it could
come in the form of a laugh but any kind
of response like that is more useful
it's the most useful thing any writer
can have a dramatic writer uh much more
useful than a focus group for example
where focus groups of any kind are false
there because you're asking people to
put
into uh verbal responses what they felt
and the average audience member is not
capable of doing that there's no reason
to expect them to be able to do that
it's hard for anybody to be able to say
what it was they felt half an hour ago
when they watch something uh they just
can't do it and it's usually not very
useful watching them live is the best
Andy you recently started a YouTube
channel and it's the go draft by Andy
gon
um you say the world doesn't need more
screenwriters it needs better movies
yeah that's part of My Philosophy for
doing it in the first place I'm not
selling a book I'm not selling a seat in
a seminar I just want to see better
movies I
I I'm a bit of an old grouch I guess but
I don't think I'm alone in saying that
there aren't a lot of great movies
anymore we're lucky to see one a year
literally one good movie a year uh much
less The Barrage of great films that I
grew up watching in the in the 70s
especially when I came of age as as a
film Watcher and fell in love with films
every week there'd be two or three great
films released and now it's there's aity
there's just a lack of uh of good movies
because I believe the craft of
screenwriting has fallen to such a low
level um there's a lot of reasons for it
doesn't really matter why but um my goal
here is just to share what I know and I
have learned a lot over 45 years of
getting paid to do this I have learned a
lot about how to tell stories in the
filmic medium so uh that's my goal I
just want to share it and and I had
taught have taught for a number of years
at UCLA and at Pepperdine universities
but I uh also when I was working uh up
until recently I I still do go in as a
consultant at Disney still but up until
recently I was a day-to-day television
writer and a headwriter and so I was
found myself teaching in to the staffs
who were desperate for this material
even though most of them been to film
School the screenwriting instruction
they'd received was not particularly
good so um or at least it wasn't useful
to them and so I realized there was a
there was a market for this I'm not
interested in try at this point in my
career I'm comfortable I don't need to
monetize it I just want to uh share it
and and if it's a value to someone seems
to be to a lot of people what I know um
why not get it out there in the world
and that's what the that's what the godd
draft is all about the term godd draft
by the way because people ask what does
that mean it used to be common in uh in
Hollywood I don't know if it is anymore
but uh they talked about the go draft
was the draft that was written that got
the green light whoever wrote The Go
draft was a prized commodity very often
they weren't even credited uh but they
they did that last pass that made the
the made the script go from promising to
okay let's start writing checks we're
going to make this film and uh that's a
lot of who I'm writing it for people who
are probably already interested or even
actively trying to be a writer a
screenwriter but their work isn't quite
up to the level of getting shot of
getting paid of getting you know moving
on to the next level of getting your
work produced and so that's hence the go
draft going back to the idea of maybe
there's less quality films made today do
you think that we watch films for
different reasons sometimes we have
things playing in the background that
we're not too emotionally invested in
it's pretty light it's pretty maybe the
people are pretty and others we go by
ourselves and we maybe we're not in the
best mood but we want to feel something
to take us out of where we are and other
people want to be sort of it's a date
movie they don't want anything too
serious we go for different reasons yeah
that's that's absolutely true I think
it's probably always been true I mean I
there were you know when you look back
at the history of Hollywood movies there
were romantic comedies and musicals and
dramas and uh film Noir and all kinds of
things so uh the difference is
especially in the last well since
streaming especially
um even before that the fragmentation of
the market through cable but as more and
more people began to experience uh 2hour
films featurelength films uh at home
rather than in the theater uh it forces
the screenwriter to capture the audience
quicker we don't have as much time as we
used to I think Robert Town used to talk
about you had 10 15 minutes before
anybody was going to start talking about
leaving so you've got them for well
that's not true anymore you don't have
you have for 10 or 15 seconds anymore
you have to capture people more quickly
uh and that's true but that's not the
certainly not the reason why uh the
craft has has gotten as uh sloppy and
ragged as it has um most films that
don't work the vast majority of them
don't work because of the script because
no this they never got the story right
or maybe they did get the story right
but then producers and stars and other
directors started monkeying with it and
pulled it out of shape very rarely are
um are films failures because they're
poorly directed or because it's not shot
well or because uh the costumes are
wrong or even if the casting is wrong
certainly can affect how effective they
are but that's not usually the reason
why a film fails it's almost always the
problems are in the
script